taking a trip underground
ukraine's president converted a kiev
subway station into a new kind of
platform
one for his first big press conference
since russia's war began
like other underground stations this
place was a bomb shelter for local
residents at the start of the invasion
now it's offering vladimir zelensky top
cover for a marathon meeting with the
world media
interrupted by the odd passing train
the focus was russia's war western
weapons and the threat of a russian
nuclear strike
also news two top white house officials
will visit for the first time since the
invasion
given that you've got the us defense
secretary coming into town on sunday and
the secretary of state and you've talked
about the importance of weapons from the
us and the uk coming quickly
can you speaking frankly set out the
danger for ukraine if your allies like
the uk like the us
stop sending weapons so fast is there a
chance that russia will take land and
seize and hold land in the east in the
south and maybe even come back to kiev
in terms of our partners
i don't believe and i don't even think
about the possibility that our partners
won't provide us with the weapons which
they promised
they have no alternative we will not
give them this opportunity we have no
other choice but to defend our land and
get it back
what would the other choice be
it would be that we have no state
no people this would be just a scorched
land
this is the only alternative which i
will never take into account
this is a man who's already seen his
country lose so much peace talks the
only way to end the suffering then must
come justice
you've said that you're willing to speak
with vladimir putin if there's a chance
to find a diplomatic path to peace but
given all that your country has been
through would you ultimately like to see
vladimir putin before a war crimes a war
crimes tribunal
regarding the meeting with the russian
president i didn't say i want i have to
see the president if we plan to solve
this issue through diplomacy whether i
want the russian leader to be presented
to the tribunal to the court it's not me
it's only him i think that all who
issued orders these shameful orders to
eliminate peaceful citizens women
children and others should be judged by
the international court
we know how long it may take we know how
the international courts work
we will wait
if not we then our children will live up
to the day when the policy of this state
will be completely ruined
after two hours it was time to leave
security tight for this station's vip
visitor his journey a very dangerous one
debra haynes sky news